[Music]
music
[Music]
welcome to the mit center for art
science and technology's 2021 symposium
unfolding intelligence the art and
science of contemporary computation
cast was established in 2012 with the
goal of building and building on
connections between the worlds of art
science and technology
this is the third in a series of
symposia the cast has convened since
then and
as with its predecessors we bring
together artists
scientists engineers and humanists from
within mit and from the world at large
to discuss areas of rapidly evolving
research and urgent
social relevance and defined in that
dialogue
stimulation confirmation provocation
intersection
and we hope common purpose
at mit cass partners with departments
labs and centers to integrate the arts
across the curriculum
to enrich and encourage artistic
collaboration and to provide support to
faculty and members of the mit community
as they pursue their own artistic
practice and or research
in addition to symposia like this cass
facilitates the sharing of this creative
work beyond the institute
by producing concerts exhibitions and
publications
and making them available to the public
so thank you for being with us today we
hope you will join us throughout the
week
at virtual events addressing the
aesthetic technical
and critical issues pertaining to
artificial intelligence
and computational media we also look
forward to seeing you
on friday april 9th as the symposium
culminates
with a live interactive event to which
all attendees are invited
and which you can join presenters and
artists in breakout rooms
to explore hidden threads between all
that has been discussed
this week
welcome to our welcome to our panel on
bias and the ai
for uh for
uh exploring all of the kind of
issues where we can understand how
algorithms have been leveraged
for a number of technological advances
at the same time as encoding
a number of types of discriminatory
practices
these days terms like bias and ai and
algorithmic bias
have nearly entered the common parlance
these days but it wasn't always the case
even though many technologies of
many technologies in the past have also
implemented bias
so for example we could think back
towards collaborative filtering
algorithms
commonly used and and
commonly benefited from today whether
it's from recommendations for purchases
or songs
and so forth at the same time when you
look at how collaborative filtering
algorithms work
these algorithms that are frequently
used in recommender systems
you can say that they build consensus in
a particular way
that can encode bias that is
you can think about a collaborative
filtering algorithm as a very is working
on a very sparse matrix that is
if you imagine a kind of a system where
you have
all of the users of the system along a
vertical axis
and all of the items that can be
recommended along the horizontal axis
you're going to know then the system is
going to try to figure out
for each for each cell would that person
want to purchase or understand or use
that particular item
so you can see that most of those cells
are going to be filled and the algorithm
is going to have to try to fill it
it would do so by trying to find
networks of users
like-minded users and build consensus
show those items to those users more and
then
you have this escalating process of
consensus building
in which case all of the individuals
will tend to converge towards similar
preferences
in fact in the early literature around
collaborative filtering algorithms
people who didn't fit neatly into the
rubric were
called in early papers either black
sheep or
white sheep tellingly fields such as
computer support cooperative work within
a computer science
have long looked at issues like the
socio-technical gap you know trying to
understand
why systems often fail for social
reasons rather than technological
reasons thinkers such as phil agri
of and terry winograd have been critics
of
ai and phil in particular suggesting
this idea of critical technical
practices
where we consider their foundations as
we think about
how we engineer systems and then
sociology of science we have people like
bruno latour who would look at how
people
and systems all within the same network
exchange values with one another
now the term bias and ai yeah has
has proliferated in part because of the
use of artificial neural networks
these used to be used 20 and 30 years
ago primarily
either for particular classes of
engineering problems or in cases
where computer scientists wanted
enhanced biological possibility
however 20 years ago they weren't as in
as widespread use as
today because such a systems
were criticized for variety of reasons
such as biologically
biological plausibility as we learned
that it's not just whether
neuron fires but the rate of fire and
much more that determines its operation
within the human brain
but now with the inception of deep
learning the classes of problems have
have expanded immensely that artificial
neural networks can approach
and because of this proliferation of
using artificial neural networks
in collusion with the enhanced media
attention around particular kind of
social issues of bias
then this topic of bias nai has become
more well known uh
as uh as jeff balker and lee starr have
put it we can combine our our technical
and scientific approaches with the
wisdom of race critical
and feminist scholarship in order to
more completely understand the kind of
operation
of these systems hence the panel
for from today is aimed to
allow us to benefit from the insights of
computer science
sociology reflective technologies from
the arts
all to gain different perspectives on
the issue of
bias and ai and i want to finally just
mention
one other point related to bias and ai
before i begin to introduce
our panelists it's that we can turn the
lens around
yes so i've been very pleased in some of
our own work
to use deep learning or statistical
techniques such as
archetypal analysis to to try to
understand
wide widely used systems such as
avatars in games and social media social
media profiles and more
and and expose the kind of biases and
and you know that they tend to implement
such as not being optimized for
particular categories of people within
as
as as regards to race or gender in
particular
so to begin with i mentioned benefiting
from the wisdom of sociology computer
science and the arts
we have first of all ruja benjamin who
specializes in interdisciplinary study
of science medicine technology race
ethnicity gender
and knowledge and power she's the author
of people science
bodies and rights on the stem cell
frontier
and race after technology
she is a professor at duke university
she has written numerous articles and
book chapters
been awarded fellowships and grants from
the national science foundation
ford foundation and much more
in a computer science and information
science we have john kleinberg
his research focuses on interaction of
algorithms and networks and the roles
they play
in large-scale social information
systems
his work has been supported by nsf
career award
onr young investigator award mcarthur
fellowship
sloan foundation fellowship and much
more as well as grants from
facebook google yahoo macarthur
foundation
and the nsf and many other organizations
and in terms of reflecting on these kind
of systems
that we have farahi here who is an
award-winning designer
critical maker based in los angeles who
holds a phd
in interdisciplinary and media arts and
practice from usc's school of cinematic
arts
she explores how to foster an empathetic
relationship between the human body
and space using a
space around it using computational
systems addressing issues ranging from
emotion
to social interaction and she uses
fabrication techniques along with
computational design in her work
her work is in the permanent collection
the museum of science and industry
and chicago she's been exhibited
internationally in ours electronica
and more and featured across the popular
press ranging from bbc to the guardian
wired and many other many other
journalistic venues and finally she is
also
a
she is also a recipient of many
fellowships
too such as the rock hudson fellowship
so i'm very very pleased to have these
uh distinguished panelists
with us here today first off is going to
be uh ruja
benjamin you will see a recorded video
of her speaking and afterwards we'll
return for
a few live clarifying questions before
continuing on with our other panelists
in a similar
format and then going to a broad
panel discussion and q a so without
further ado i'd like to
hand it off and begin the uh and begin
with
the presentation thank you so much for
the invitation to be part of this
conversation
when it comes to our theme unfolding
intelligence i want to suggest that
to talk about intelligence is to talk
about
eugenics for many people the e-word
conjures a particular place nazi germany
forgetting that the nazis learned from
us-based scientists and doctors and that
hitler called madison grant's book the
passing of the great race
his bible the word eugenics also
conjures a specific
time period that we have supposedly
passed
when in fact eugenic logics and
imaginaries
continue to infect so many areas of our
contemporary lives
from the way patients are treated and
triaged
to the way that school children are
ranked
and rated in short the eugenics period
never ended but rather unfolded
mercurial in the way that it has taken
on different forms and functions
including in our present age of ai
for our conversation today i want to
briefly highlight the entanglement
between
eugenics and statistics and since we're
still in the midst of the spring
semester i'd like to assign some
homework
and encourage everyone to read this
article authored by aubry clayton
a few months ago published a few months
ago in it she writes that
ideally statisticians would like to
divorce
these tools from the lives and times of
the people
who created them it would be convenient
if statistics existed outside of history
but that's not the case statistics as a
lens through which scientists
investigate real-world questions
has always been smudged by the
fingerprints of the people
holding the lens statistical thinking
and eugenicist thinking are in fact
deeply intertwined and many of the
theoretical problems with methods like
significance testing first developed to
identify
racial differences are remnants of their
original
purpose to support eugenics
in other words eugenics haunts any
discussion
of ut of intelligence so if statistical
thinking will not save us
what will black feminists thought of
course
and here i draw upon the wisdom of tony
k bambara when she writes
not all speed is movement
again this idea could be applied to so
many different
areas of our lives but here i want us to
think about
it in the context of technological
development
which too often is conflated falsely
with social progress technological
development can actually
reinforce and sediment social
inequalities in fact its default
settings
should have it that we shouldn't be
surprised when it does and
you know this idea is easier to
translate and to shape our critical
thinking when it comes to the past
it's easier to recognize when technology
and data have been used to harm
different groups whether it's the deadly
data uh that ibm helped in supporting
the holocaust in terms of punch cards to
surveil and track populations that were
eventually exterminated but
it's harder i think to apply this to our
present especially when it comes to what
we might call
do-gooding data where the framing and
the motive
is to purportedly help different groups
in this case a quick example comes to us
from minnesota where the public school
district there and the police department
joined forces
under the umbrella of what they call the
innovation project
and you know this was a project that
intended to collect
and centralize data from a number of
different
local agencies in order to
help predict the riskiness of young
people
their risk of having future encounters
with law enforcement
the do-gooding aspect was that these
agencies hoped to
intervene early but ultimately the
community
community rallied around and put an end
to this innovation project
pointing to the fact that the vast
majority of these agencies
actually did not have a good track
record when it came to
supporting the well-being of young
people they they pointed in particular
to the data that would be used
as the input for this project the
different
attendance records whether family
members had been involved with
child tria with the criminal justice
system child protective services
so all of the input data actually were
drawn from agencies and institutions
that have routinely
harm surveil and mistreat young people
so why should the community expect a
different outcome
a good outcome and so again it's harder
to think about
this critically in light of the
questions of eugenics and how this
supports the ranking
and the rating of different groups and
so
as a starting point to think critically
about our present moment our do-gooding
efforts
i want to suggest that when it comes to
computational depth deep learning
machine
learning without historical and
sociological depth what we're actually
producing
is superficial learning we really have
to situate
our questions and our designs and our
goals in a much
deeper historical and social context so
that we don't unwittingly
reproduce racial inequalities um and
social inequities
and so let's apply this insight just for
a moment
to a particular setting let's look at it
in the context of health care
again there's there's mounds of of
research that really shows the various
ways in which racial discrimination
operates
in our health care system and it's not
simply at the structural level
although that's important that is at the
level of policies and laws
but also interpersonally in terms of the
way that health care
professionals treat different patients
and
one set of a part of this literature is
looking at how
doctors routinely underestimate the pain
of black patients
um and don't prescribe them the
necessary treatments and medication that
they might need so
a question for us would be you know what
would it look like to actually
outsource these decisions to ai would
that make it more fair more equitable
would that be a way to bypass
the existing social biases and forms of
discrimination
in our health care system and so my
recent work has been wrestling with this
and similar questions in which i
describe the combination of
coded bias and imagined objectivity
as the new gym code innovation that
enables social containment while
appearing
fairer than discriminatory practices of
a previous era
what i'm drawing attention to with this
concept is
that technology can actually hide the
ongoing nature
of social domination and allow it to
penetrate every facet of our lives
under the guise of progress and what i'm
encouraging us to think about
is how anti-blackness gets encoded in
and
exercised through automated systems by
offering four conceptual offspring to
the new gym code that follow along kind
of spectrum
from the most obvious variety engineered
inequity
to the most insidious techno benevolence
and for the sake of time i'm just going
to sketch the last
element of this techno benevolence and
then move towards some concluding
thoughts
so techno benevolence refers to those
technologies that
aim to address bias in various ways
take for example new ai techniques for
vetting job applicants
a company called higher view aims to
quote reduce
unconscious bias and promote diversity
in the workplace
by using an ai powered program that
analyzes
recorded interviews of prospective
employees
so it uses thousands of data points
including
verbal and nonverbal cues like facial
expression
posture vocal tone and then it compares
job seekers scores to those of existing
top performing employees to decide who
to flag as a desirable hire
and who to reject another value added
according to higher view is that there's
a lot that a human
interviewer misses that ai can keep
track of
to make quote data driven talent
decisions
after all the problem of employment
discrimination
is widespread and well-documented so the
logic goes
wouldn't this be even more reason to
outsource decisions to ai
we'll consider that question in light of
a study by a princeton team of computer
scientists that examined whether
a popular algorithm trained on human
writing online
exhibited the same racially biased
tendencies
that psychologists have documented among
humans
in particular they found that the
algorithm associated white
sounding names with pleasant words and
black sounding names with unpleasant
ones
which builds on a classic audit study
from about 2003
in which two university of chicago
economists sent out thousands of resumes
to
employers in boston and chicago and just
changed the names on the resumes some
had
names like emily and greg some names
like lakeisha
and jamal and what they found was that
the white sounding names
received 50 more callbacks and so simply
turning to technology to solve that form
of employment bias
is not going to save us so too with
gender-coded words and names as
amazon learned a few years ago when its
own hiring algorithm
was found discriminating against women
nevertheless it should be clear why
technical fixes
that claim to bypass human biases are so
desirable if only there was a way to
slay
centuries of racist and sexist demons
with a social justice bot
beyond desirable more like magical
magical for employers perhaps
looking to streamline the grueling work
of recruitment
but a curse from any job seekers as this
headline puts it
your next interview could be with a
racist spot
bringing us back to that problem space
we started with
so it's it's worth noting that some job
seekers are already developing
ways to subvert the system by trading
answers to employers tests and creating
fake applications
as informal audits of their own in terms
of public policy
the algorithmic accountability bill is
one
effort in the us to create some
protections around the ubiquity of
automated and ai based decisions in our
everyday lives
it's a start but in no way sufficient
another development that keeps me
somewhat hopeful is
that tech workers themselves have
increasingly been speaking out
against the most egregious forms of
corporate collusion
with state-sanctioned racism for example
microsoft employees
opposed to the company's ice contract
stated that
as the people who build the technologies
that microsoft profits from
we refuse to be complicit and in just
the last few months the alphabet workers
union has been gaining momentum and so
for anyone in the tech industry
listening here i would encourage you to
look up these efforts and stay connected
and as this article published by science
for the people reminds us
contrary to popular narratives
organizing among technical workers
has a vibrant history including
engineers and technicians in the 60s and
70s who
fought professionalism individualism and
reformism
to contribute to radical labor
organizing
the current tech workers movement which
includes students across our many
institutions
can draw from these past organizers
strategies and challenges
and learning to navigate the
contradictions and complexities of
organizing in tech today
in terms of education which i think of
as the ground zero for planting a more
historically and socially situated
approach to stem
i'll just mention one concrete resource
that you can download
called the advancing racial literacy
and in tech handbook which was developed
by some wonderful colleagues
at the data and society research
institute in new york
the aim of this intervention is
threefold
to develop an intellectual understanding
of how
structural racism operates in algorithms
social media platforms and technologies
not yet developed
and emotional intelligence concerning
how to resolve racially stressful
situations within organizations and
a commitment to take action to reduce
harms to communities of color
in that spirit initiatives like data for
black lives and the detroit community
tech project
are just two of the many different tech
justice organizations that exist all
over the world
data for black lives brings together
people working across a number of
agencies and organizations in a
proactive approach to tech justice
especially at the policy level and the
detroit community technology project
develops and uses technology rooted in
community needs
offering support to grassroots networks
doing data justice research
including hosting what they call
discotex
which stands for discovering technology
which are these multimedia mobile
neighborhood workshop fares that can be
adapted in other locales
in the end it boils down to whose
knowledge or we might say
whose intelligence we're unfolding into
our
socio-technical systems who are we
listening to
returning to the issue of medical racism
it turns out
if ai is trained on doctors reports
it will draw discriminatory and faulty
conclusions
according to the researchers we didn't
train the algorithm to predict what the
doctor was going to say about the x-ray
we trained it
to predict what the patient was going to
say about their own
experience of pain in the knee and the
these predictions
from the patient's reports were actually
much more accurate
who would have guessed so here's my
final proposition
if it is the case that inequity
and injustice is woven into the very
fabric
of our society then that means each
twist
coil and code is a chance for us to
weave new patterns
practices and politics the vastness of
the problems that we're up against will
be their undoing
once we accept that we are pattern
makers
and so if as i suggested at the start
and a historic and asocial approach to
science and technology
captures and contains that means a
historically and socially grounded
approach can open up possibilities and
pathways
it can create new settings and code new
values
and build on critical intellectual
traditions
that have continuously developed
insights and strategies grounded
in justice and my hope is that we all
find ways
to build on this tradition thank you for
your attention
so thank you so much for the fascinating
and incisive
talk and one of the things i was struck
by
was the way that you describe the kind
of
uh benevolence you know the kind of
so-called benevolence
approach that people might bring to
these uh you know
to these communities you know as if a
kind of a savior model in
particular ways you know so i wonder if
you if
you could look at the other side and and
say a bit more about what you see
as community projects that have been
successful
that are emerging from within
communities and you know this is what
one of my students has called
critical community technologies and what
are the conditions under which you've
seen such
such groups of flourish where they have
been the ones leveraging these
technologies
yeah thank you so much fox and thanks to
all the organizers behind the screen
um helping us to convene in this uh
space and this conversation
and so you know there's there's
different ways that this is taking shape
and i and i think
that there's no one set of conditions
or requirements that i think can make
technology more empowering less
oppressive
um the ones that i find fascinating
is when the these digital tools are
turned back on those who
wield power and monopolize resources
um sometimes in longer versions of the
talk i'll
i'll mention a a parody example called
the white collar early warning system
which is not
community based but it's an artist a
creative sort of rendering of what it
means to take these tools that are
typically targeting um you know the most
disenfranchised communities
and turn it back to those who produce
risk
for those very same populations and so
there's examples like that kind of
subversive
turning of the digital tools that
sometimes enroll or collaborate with
communities to make happen
then there are the examples that i
hinted at like the detroit community
technology project
um there's a new york there's a new york
based version of that in which
you know it's really about generating
meaningful questions
as a starting point for any kind of
design project i think sometimes when we
think about community collaboration
researchers we huddle we come up with
something and then we go out and try to
find communities to collaborate with
rather than really starting at ground
zero with the generation of questions to
me that's where
so much of the power is concentrated the
fact that people can't ask
meaningful questions about their lives
about their world and then have the
resources
to produce the data produce the tools
that would help them
ask answer and intervene in those issues
and so one of the places that i'm trying
to work on that is
at the ida b wells just data lab here at
princeton
in which i have teams of undergrad
students
who partner with communities to generate
questions and then the projects that
come out of that as a
as to me a better starting point so
rather than us think about okay this is
what we want to do and then go find
community partners
so the ida b wells just data lab is one
example
housed in academia but there are other
you know
examples that come out of more policy or
advocacy
um sort of orientation there are
anti-surveillance
types of projects some that are more
creative
um in which people are creating fashion
that are sort of anti-surveillance
fashion
examples versus like the lapd's uh
uh coalition to stop um uh surveillance
in
los angeles and other places so i think
the take home is that
this can take many many different forms
from
uh you know on a continuum of more
critical
countering subversive to creative
self-fashioning
and you know community-based you know
participatory research
whether that's in the context of
environmental justice or data justice
um there are so many examples and so for
those who are looking to plug in i would
encourage
them to visit the resources tab of my
personal website
benjamin.com backslash resources and
you'll see a really long
list of places to plug in in your own
backyard
and especially for the students who
might be listening you know sometimes
when we
we are awakened to issues like this we
want to start our own thing
you know the kind of entrepreneurial
spirit and i would encourage us to plug
into things that already exist as a
starting point
rather than jump the gun and try to try
to come up the solutions going back to
your savior
the idea of a savior complex uh and so
i i hope that gives folks enough to chew
on as a
as a place to get started it does it's
so
fascinating and you bring to mind
projects such as the million dollar
blocks project looking at the amount of
money
mapping the amount of money used in
communities to
for incarceration it prompts people to
think about other types of issues and
where the money could have
gone you know so that it just seems like
exactly the kind of
literacy in reversing the lens that you
describe
and uh so thank you thank you once again
very much
and so next up we have john kleinberg
professor at cornell university who's
going to speak
and i think it's a very nice compliment
to what we've just seen
from uh professor ruha benjamin now
because
he's looking in some sense uh under the
hood
but at the same time bringing that kind
of uh critical lens around
issues of uh fairness as well so now
let's uh
welcome our pre-recorded video by uh
john kleinberg followed again by a brief
for clarifying q
a it's a pleasure to be uh
able to take part in this event today
and i'll be talking about
uh topics in fairness and bias in
algorithmic
decision making and i'll be approaching
this uh as a computer scientist but what
i'll be talking about
is uh joint work with my phd student
manish raghavan
and then with three researchers from
uh three other domains from jen sludwig
in public policy sentinel william authen
in behavioral economics
and cass sunstein who's a professor of
law
and in some sense to frame what i'll be
talking about it's
useful to actually go back to a period
of time when i was a
phd student at at mit in the mid 1990s
and that there was a lot of excitement
at that moment about the way in which an
idea that had been
really ubiquitous in fields like human
computer interaction
uh suddenly became mainstream through
much of computer science and that was
the idea that the systems we were
designing really had these two different
axes that we had to think about
there was the technical axis along which
we had always organized things
but then there was also a social
dimension right where we built systems
and we needed to be sensitive to
the social and economic forces that
underpin them in some genuine sense that
period through the 1990s when we saw the
emergence of systems like the world wide
web
we really saw the building of
socio-technical systems
but over the past 10 years particularly
we've been
discovering that you know these systems
uh
even when we take both of these into
account don't always produce the
outcomes that we were hoping
they end up being awash in
misinformation
they can lead to conflict and
polarization they can produce decisions
that seem biased against particular
groups of people it's almost as though
there's this
third dimension that we haven't been
taking into account and
much of the momentum in the past 10
years of research at the interface of
computing
and the social sciences has really been
trying to explore what this third
dimension
might look like and if i were to
summarize
i might say it's almost as though
there's this normative dimension that
we've been missing in the design of our
systems
that even if we fully understand which
we certainly don't the social and
technical forces
at play it none even with all of that it
does not tell us
uh what outcomes we should be aiming for
right what what we might want as a
sus as a society that in the end is
a different question and so i want to
talk about from
the computer science perspective how
some of these issues have come into play
in the algorithms
the ai systems and the
machine learning protocols that we have
been trying to deploy
much of this begins with a observation
that people have been making that's
gathered increasing amount of force in
the past few years as well
which is to take ideas that we have been
very good at
executing in the online world things
like ranking
things like recommendation as in this
this help screen from a
netflix page where we take people online
and we you know with complex sets of
tastes and interests
we produce feature vectors that
represent them
and then we try to make a prediction for
example the pre you know a prediction
about whether they will like this
particular
movie what is the probability they will
like this movie um
and people began asking if we are so
good at doing this in the online world
let's think about situations in the in
the offline world
where there's something that looks
syntactically similar going on
right so let's think about something
that superficially is quite different
which is the act of applying for a job
if we think about it we take somebody
with their complex past work experience
they produce a tabular feature-like
representation in the form of a
resume they submitted to a human hiring
committee that evaluates it right a very
similar pipeline
and that committee then makes some kind
of uh
well it's not clear what they do right
they evaluate some objective function do
they make a prediction
this is actually where it gets kind of
complicated and that tension is actually
what i'll be trying to get at in
my talk a similar thing happens with the
college admissions process
you take someone's grade 9 through 12
educational history
their interests and so forth turn into a
feature representation
and again a committee might make a
decision with an unclear objective
function
so many things following this kind of
template
right things that we might call
screening decisions
right so when somebody applies for a job
there has to be a decision made
um educational mission decisions and
many other domains
the you know applications for
a loan and the domain of credit uh even
in the
criminal justice system where the law
instructs a judge
uh at a pre-trial detention hearing to
make a prediction
about the uh the likelihood that a
defendant will return for their court
appearance uh without committing a crime
in the meantime
and so these are all what you might call
high stakes decisions these are
decisions
where the outcome matters significantly
to
the individual being screened right so
it matters a lot if you get this job you
apply for if you get into this college
you apply for and you know
all these other examples this is not to
say that
ranking and recommendation of online
content um
are somehow overall low stakes
activities
you know in the end it certainly does
not matter whether netflix gets right
whether i like this movie
in the end it doesn't matter whether
this particular search results page has
the result i was particularly looking
for but we've also seen over the past
few years that you can take 100 billion
of these low stakes decisions
right search results news feed decisions
and they can add up to something
that is extremely high stakes like the
formation of public opinion as part of
the political process in a
in a large country so everything that we
do in this domain i think has
giant ramifications the stakes are high
i sort of focus on these screen
decisions as being
individually high stakes each individual
decision is actually significant
and because of this it's very natural
and research has turned to this question
of the risks of bias in these kinds of
decisions when we deploy algorithms to
make them
or when we deploy groups of humans to
make them and so if we're going to think
about the ways in which
algorithms might introduce bias into
this process
we should really start by thinking about
what we know about human bias
in these situations because human bias
is a profound factor
in in in all of these domains
now well there's been an extensive
amount of research in the behavioral
sciences on
human biases and including an explosion
of work
in the 1990s on topics in
implicit bias and a number of now
classical
investigations looked at this question
empirically
and they found things that are sort of
illustrated by for example this uh graph
on the on the right here which i'll
explain this comes from a
paper in nature in 1997 by the
european social scientist christine
venevos and agnes vold
and so that they're interested in the
disparate impact of screening decisions
as as we are here today and so what they
did was they got records of
um decisions that were made on european
research commission grant proposals
and as part of that process the reviewer
of the proposal was supposed to assign a
so-called
competence score to the principal
investigator how competent are they to
do
the research and so that's some kind of
a numerical score and
veneras and fold were interested in this
case in potential disparate impacts
in the assignment of this confidence
score by by
gender okay and so what they did was
they
looked at many different measures of
external impact for this researcher they
looked at
publications number of publications in
high profile venues citations those
publications
success at past european research
commission grant proposals and so forth
and they put that on the x-axis and then
on the y-axis
they plotted the confidence score and
what we see here
is that if i pick a particular point on
the x-axis a particular
value of the external impact and i start
to move vertically
we see that the typical competence score
for principal investigators who were men
was significantly higher
than for women or if i could
pick a particular point on the y-axis
and i move horizontally
then what i find is that for a
particular competence score
women as principal investigators needed
significantly higher measures of
external impact in order to achieve that
and this was one of many studies
around this time that tried this
research methodology find people
who are similar in the features that
they are
presenting to the decision and are
nonetheless getting very different
outcome
and thereby discovering some of the ways
in which this breaks down
along the lines of what the law
considers to be protected attributes
so this is an illustration of human bias
in an empirical context now when we move
to
algorithms and we consider the idea of
algorithms making similar decisions that
we might train an algorithm
to engage in a predictive activity to
make a decision like this
we face a different sort of situation
first
algorithms in contrast to humans have no
direct incentives to exhibit bias
that's essentially by definition the
algorithm after all
knows really in the end nothing about
the world it doesn't know who you are
it's simply been trained to optimize
this objective function despite this
what we've learned in the past several
years of research is that there are many
sources of potential bias
in algorithms and we can try
conceptually to decompose these into
some constituent parts so for example
the choice of label or objective
function that i'm trying to predict
right the target of my prediction
and we can see how this might happen you
know suppose for example
that i were trying to train an algorithm
to assign a competence score in
evaluating european research commission
grant proposals
i might feed it training data right just
the administrative data of the
administration of this program over many
years
what scores were assigned to which grant
proposals in the process it would
learn to make these predictions and it
might pick up on
therefore the gender disparity that was
already in the data
right it's simply trying to faithfully
approximate the trained data that's been
given
similarly we could see that in the uh
in the features which i handed right if
i'm trying to have it predict
other things but one thing that i handed
is the so-called confidence score of the
researcher
then it essentially has a feature that
already has that bias
built into it these are the kinds of
points that we
that we think about now if we want to
look at sources of bias and algorithms
then
we face an interpretability challenge we
have to actually be able to
look into the algorithm and try to
understand what's
what's what's going on but a first point
i'd like to make
is that interpretability is not only an
issue
for algorithms in fact much of
discrimination law
is actually built if you think about it
with the idea that human decision making
is likewise inscrutable and
uninterpretable
because in the end the law actually
recognizes two categories of
discrimination
this is in u.s
discrimination law where the terminology
is disparate treatment versus disparate
impact
just for treatment deliberately favoring
one applicant
say in our running example of something
like hiring
based on a protected attribute like race
gender national origin religion
or age and separately desperate impact
the the notion that regardless of intent
if a screening decision
has a disproportionate adverse effect on
a protected group
then the burden of proof shifts to the
decision maker to establish the business
necessity of their
decision right such that if i were
hiring people for a job that regularly
involved
reaching things in extremely high places
then i might want employees who were
taller even if that has a
disproportionate adverse effect based on
gender for example
but if i were hiring software engineers
and i put in a height requirement then
it would be very very hard to justify
that on grounds of business
necessity now the point is it can be
very hard to tell
if a decision maker has engaged in
disparate treatment or in
desperate impact and there are a few
reasons for this
the most immediate is that it's very
hard to ask people
they might they might lie they might be
deceptive in in the evidence that they
present but there's also a deeper reason
a reason coming from the behavioral
sciences which is
they might genuinely not know the
rationale they used
for their decision right and so
there's actually a long history of work
in
in the in the behavioral sciences
establishing that when people provide
you with explanations for their
decisions
um those may or may not be accurate
renditions of what actually went into
their decision
how could we possibly know that well
some of this work goes back to a series
of very creative experiments done by
nisbet and wilson in the 1970s
where they would create lab situations
ask people to make decisions
and then with a second group they would
subtly change some feature of the
environment
get the decision to change and then ask
people why they made their decision
and often people's explanations had
nothing to do with the one feature of
the environment that changed
that's kind of abstract so let me make
that very concrete with an example from
one of their experiments
one of their experiments they gave
people a word recall task
so they would um they would ask people
to memorize a list of words recite it
back and then at the end they would ask
a non-sequitur question
name a brand of laundry detergent okay
in group b they would do the same thing
but in the word recall task
the words they would ask people uh to
memorize were things like
beach ocean moon
waves sea and so forth and then when
they said name a brand of laundry
detergent many more people said
tied now this is the effect of priming
right priming is that if i tell you a
bunch of words
and then i ask you to think of a word
you often think of a word that's kind of
right in the vicinity of all those words
by the process of free association
but nisbet wilson did one more step
which was extremely clever
they asked people why did you pick that
brand of
laundry detergent and in both groups a
and b
both conditions of the experiment people
said it's because it's the one my family
used when i was growing up
it's the one we use at home i remember
the logo from the store
people in the second group did not say
it's because you primed me with a lot of
words that made me think of tied
even though statistically we know that
many of those people must have been
primed because there was a big
difference
in how many people said tied in the two
groups so
there are many other nisbet wilson
experiments in a different one you ask
people to choose clothes from iraq you
orient the rack to get them to choose
the one on the right
uh you know with high probability yet
when people are asked why they chose the
article of clothing they mentioned the
style or the color and not the fact that
you had oriented things to essentially
force that one on them
in other words what's essentially going
on here is that
it's a set of findings that sort of
should make us think a little harder
about
you know the notion of interpretability
and inscrutability as we often apply it
to algorithms
because it says although people are
always happy to give you
the sense of an explanation they're
always happy to say this is why i did
something
the harder question is to know whether
that explanation is correct
right in some sense humans in their own
way are inscrutable or black boxes in
their decision making we can't always
know why they did what they did
and that we argue actually presents an
interesting opportunity
right beyond the question of whether
algorithms are increasing
or decreasing the level of
discrimination in a particular situation
which is
an important question that the the field
has been thinking about
we argue there's a second question which
is the ways in which albert
well-regulated algorithms
can make discrimination uh easier to
detect
the point being that even an algorithm
that's extremely complex
trained through an extremely long
pipeline of training with very large
amounts of training data
despite all of that it has certain
properties that we can never expect from
human decision makers
right obviously you know
it's not that we can simply read the
code and expect to understand the
algorithm right there are all sorts of
reasons ranging from
the difficulty the cognitive difficulty
of reading code to
formal results and undecidability that
tell us that but we can do some things
you could never do with a human being
you can for example if the algorithm is
available for inspection
examine the objective function that's
being optimized
right whereas with human decision makers
we can never really ask somebody
what is your objective function right
think of all the situations in which
you've been called on to evaluate people
you would have a hard time writing down
your formal objective function that
situation
we can provide the algorithm with
counter factuals we can say here's
somebody who was evaluated
i'm going to change certain features and
i'm going to run this through the
classifier again
and see if the result changes again with
a human being
you could ask somebody would you have
made the same decision
if this person had graduated from school
x instead of school y
and they might be even in good faith
attempt to give you an answer to that
question
but there's no way to really know if
that's actually what they would have
done
so the point is algorithms aren't just a
change in accuracy
or scale or quantity relative to humans
they're doing something
dramatically different they have an
explicit formal
process that they're following with
explicit features an explicit
objective function something that we can
actually trace even if we can't follow
the code
and so we can probe them uh you know
almost as a natural experiment in ways
that we could never do
with human beings and so in this
final couple minutes of the talk i
wanted to ask what kinds of things might
we learn
if we can probe an algorithm in this way
and so
i'll introduce a bit of notation to be
able to talk about this
but it it leads to the observation that
this ways in which we can decompose
algorithmic bias can actually be made
formally in a certain sense so how might
we
make this formal well let's think about
a
machine learning pipeline and again
let's think about the notion of a
well-regulated algorithm meaning that
the features the training process the
objective function are available for
inspection
that's clearly crucial in any of this
analysis so we have individuals
they have feature vectors we have a
something that the screener is trying to
optimize let's call it a productivity
function
we're concerned about bias so we have an
advantage group
call it a and a disadvantage group let's
call it d
and finally the frequency of different
feature vectors in these populations
are different right so the frequency of
feature vector x and group a is some
function p of x a and in group d it's
p of x d so the point might be that
given the full feature vector x it
doesn't matter what group somebody comes
from the advantage group or the
disadvantage group
because x contains everything we need to
evaluate the productivity function
nevertheless there might be a disparity
between these two groups because of the
way those feature vectors are
distributed
right that a might have an abundance of
feature vectors conferring
high outcomes in the screening process
and d might have an abundance of future
vectors conferring lower outcomes
right so in particular we could compute
the average value of f
in both group a and group d let's call
that v a of f
and v d of f and we could look at
now what sociologists might call the
structural disadvantage
namely d of f is now the difference in
averages
it's the difference between the average
value in a and the average value in d
right now this is something which pre
precedes the introduction of the
algorithm this was already present in
society
and so while we might want to use the
algorithm to remediate that it's
important to realize that that is
something that predates the algorithm
it's not a case not a question about
what the album has added to the process
now the algorithm will morph this
function
and so for any function not just
f we might end up being interested in
disparity let's call that
d of w right so the difference in
averages for any function w
now let's think about the ways in which
the algorithm changed this function as
it goes right so first of all
the algorithm designer is going to use a
function g instead of f right because
the real f is not accessible to them so
they're going to use an approximation
second the full feature vector x is not
accessible to them
so they're going to use r and r of x
instead of the full x and finally
because r of x is much shorter than x
they're going to use a transformed
objective some shortened function h
composed with r instead of g and finally
this will be a training procedure that
produces a function t
instead of h so at the beginning we had
d
of f the structural disadvantage but at
the end of this pipeline
we have d of t composed with r the
trained function on the reduced
representation
and now the final point is that we
actually see that we can
take this disparity the disparity in t
composed with r produced by the machine
learning algorithm
and break it into these four components
the structural disadvantage that
preceded
the the algorithm's introduction
followed by
the bias from the choice of outcome g
instead of f the bias from the choice of
features
reduce representation r of x instead of
x and finally the bias from the training
procedure
t instead of the true approximate
function h
okay and so it actually says we can once
we have access to the pipeline we can
actually do this decomposition
and with that i wanted to wrap up again
algorithms
are presenting us with an interesting
opportunity right human decision making
contains bias as we've seen algorithmic
decision-making contains bias
but there's a certain kind of
detectability of bias and algorithmic
decision making
that's really unprecedented if we
compare it to human decision making
if they contain explicit ingredients
that allow us to attribute components of
the decision
to aspects of the screening process
this will only happen with regulations
in place that allow us to examine the
machine learning pipeline
but with that in place it really creates
very interesting opportunities going
forward and one in which many fields are
going to have to play a part
thanks very much
thank you so much john for the really
insightful talk and
yeah and one of the things that struck
me was just the parallel
use of the term socio-technical gap
from the intro and of course from your
talk here
and one of the things i love about your
work
is that you're looking deeply at the
socio
at the social side as well as
investigating particular formalisms
that can be deployed to either explain
or implement
systems and so following that line one
question that i have relating to your
work
is in in your paper on algorithmic
fairness you know that that
relates to a lot of the topics you spoke
about yeah i was really struck
by you know your your central argument
which is that
the strategy of blinding you know
algorithm the an algorithm's race
inadvertently detracts from fairness
and what that really reminded me on the
social side
is of eduardo bania silva's work on
colorblind racism in which he describes
certain kind of frameworks
that relate to colorblind ideology and
how it not only detracts from fairness
but actually discriminates so for him
that's abstract liberalism
naturalizing racist outcomes like
redlining cultural racism minimizing of
racism
and so i just wonder if you could help
to build a bridge
from your your comments yeah and
your insights about the limitations of
landing algorithms to race
and uh yeah and the notion of a
colorblind
racism and the way that that might
actually
implement particular types of
discrimination
yeah thanks thanks very much for that
question and uh i think it's
the kind of question that i certainly
you know look forward to
hearing the other panelists thoughts on
as well because i think this you know i
definitely appreciate being in this kind
of a conversation you know with uh
so many perspectives represented i think
as a
right i think from the computer science
side i think we
you know we always need to be careful
about um
you know the ways in which uh
right these you know these issues of
bias for example come in through things
that we construct that we often
you know think of as part of the given
statement of the question you know so i
thought i thought your example at the
very beginning of this session on
recommender systems you know sort of is
one
one example of this i think any any time
that we we set up a
ranking of people or a clustering of
people we have to choose some kind of
objective what does it mean for people
to be similar
you know and we often say we start from
this similarity metric and then we put a
lot of work into the clustering or the
ranking
but of course you know obviously a sort
of huge and
often you know untold number of unstated
assumptions went into the construction
of that objective function
that that we take as um as
given in in the statement of of the
question and so so i think that's
one dimension of the gap you know that i
think you're
you know i i think that we're all
thinking about that there's been this
territory that
somehow i think each side of the
discussion you know has
sometimes assumed that perhaps the other
one was somehow trying to get under
control and
in fact wasn't that you know the on the
computer science side will sometimes
take the problem formulation
as a given you know at some low level
and then we'll work very hard on sort of
extending it from there
but of course a lot of that represented
choices that um you know uh that
i think uh incorporated the bias i think
the same thing happens
again sort of the thing about the the
connection to some of the things you're
saying
in the construction of features all of
these systems
you know no system is dealing with the
person you know
every algorithmic system is dealing with
a representation and
and so i think the choice of encodings
on the choice of
representation which is again i think
very much in the theme of
some of the events going on here is is
is again something that often
you know in the in the modeling of the
problem people take that as given they
say i'm going to start from the fact
that you've represented individuals
you've represented applicants you've
represented users you've represented
readers of the news
all these things using a certain
collection of features or at least some
kind of
formalism and then i'll do the best i
can from there and so i think
you know a lot of the question is to
actually ask where did that
representation come from
what does that encode
i think it's it's i think such a
fascinating area and we don't have a lot
of time before we go
to to our next speaker you know but
maybe
just as planting food for thought for
later i feel like one of the
one of the central dialogues we can you
know points of dialogue we can have
within this
panel is about the essential assumptions
within each field
and sometimes there's a sense yeah so
i'm coming from computer science
myself as well and there can be a sense
that if you're using
algorithmic or formalist approaches then
you're taking a reductionistic approach
to society and i think what your work
shows is that
you can use formalisms to address
subjective issues in ways that
really provide additional insight you
know that can be useful for those
subjective social issues as well so i
hope we can pick up the point
about the role of formalization and how
it's not always reductive it works such
as norse later
thanks and uh looking forward to that
thanks so much and so next up you know
we have
uh benaz farahi who will speak from a
different perspective
and uh begins and her recorded talk
will provide insights from an artistic
point of view you know
bringing together our trifecta of
sociology computer science and the arts
and in particular looking at reflective
and interpretive issues around uh such a
around these issues of bias and ai so
let's begin uh
uh benaz's presentation
[Music]
so
we live in an age where we are immersed
in the world of machine learning
algorithms
computer vision and biometric sensors
but what does this all mean might these
computational systems not replicate
somewhat disturbingly our underlying
biases
and serve to reinforce the
marginalization of those who have
typically been excluded is a.i
necessarily complicit in replicating
human prejudice
or are there ways of deploying ai as a
mean of exposing human bias
i would suggest that there are potential
strategies that could be deployed for
ai to actually overcome bias
in this presentation i'm going to
address notions of the gaze
surveillance and ways of seeing through
the lens of my own creative practice
by implementing computer vision
technologies i hope to examine
how different strategies of the gaze can
be seen to undermine various forms of
power structure
and to promote forms of resistance
[Music]
here i'm trying to avoid any form of
technological determinism
rather than rehashing arguments as to
whether surveillance is good or bad
i hope to take an intersectional
feminist approach to show what
constitute the gaze and surveillance
and to consider what the strategies of
resistance
might be proved to be effective in art
and design practices
[Music]
in my work i have used various computer
vision technologies to enhance human
perception
for example this is an emotive variable
which can recognize and respond to the
facial expressions of people around
the different type of behaviors this
type of
smart soft robotic garments could
potentially benefit those with autism
who have difficulties recognizing facial
[Music]
expressions
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
another work a reticence is an emotive
color
equipped with a facial tracking camera
an array of
rotating quills which respond to the
movement of onlookers and their facial
expressions
similar to how a blind person could
sense through
haptic information the movement of the
variable
would allow the wearer to sense where
people are standing
and the emotions they're expressing even
with her eyes closed
[Music]
here i hope to address two questions
related to the notion of the gays
firstly what does it mean to be observed
secondly
what do we see when we look out at the
word
through my argument i use gaze as an
interchangeable concept which could be
shared between human
and machine this takes us to the
historical concept of panopticon
the panopticon refers to a type of
institutional building and a system of
control
envisioned by english philosopher jeremy
benton
in 18th century the layout of the
panopticon allows a guard
to observe occupants without them
knowing whether or not
they're being watched
[Music]
french philosopher michel foucault
revitalizes interest in the panopticon
in his 1975 book discipline and punish
and uses it to illustrate such a model
could be applied to disciplinary
societies
in order to control their citizens he
described the prisoner of a panopticon
as being at the receiving end of a
symmetrical
surveillance as a consequence the inmate
policies himself
for fear of punishment what is
fascinating about this example is that
rather than external actions the gaze of
the watcher is internalized to such an
extent that each prisoner
become his or her own watch person
similarly we could argue that this is
what allows rules and regulation to be
internalized
so as to inform our actions behaviors
and even our beliefs
[Music]
moreover the manner in which we
naturalize and internalize rules it
could be claimed
causes society to be less willing to
contest unjust laws
and accepted dominant outlook
similar to how the inmates are not aware
whether or not they're being watched
we are not aware that we have been
controlled through naturalized dominant
rules rooted in our
own culture
this internalized asymmetrical power
structure
could be seen in the notion of male gaze
in her essay on visual pleasure and
narrative cinema
laurel movie exposes the asymmetry of
social and political power relations
between men and women
mulvey claims that the male gaze serves
to depict women
as the object of pleasure for the
heterosexual male viewer
besides the fact that women are
regularly subject to sexual harassment
whenever they
enter public space through various forms
of looked at-ness
women have absorbed all this
unconsciously as a form of
internalized male gaze
what if women were to subvert this
through the power of their gaze
[Music]
could we drop in computer vision
technologies to allow women to know
when onlookers are staring at them
augmented with facial and gaze tracking
technology and smart materials
this cape responds to the onlooker's
gaze
the project engages with broader social
issues
such as the male gaze on the female body
the facial tracking algorithm in this
piece detects
age gender and gaze of the onlooker
while we know that gender is
performative and it doesn't depend on
pure representation
the movement of the garment based on the
viewer's gaze
could unfold a new sets of social
meanings
if you are the bearer you know which
part of your body is being looked at
and if you are an onlooker you know that
your action is being noticed
the aim is to see how different
strategies could be used to undermine
the patriarchal system
by developing form of resistance using
surveillance technology
[Music]
i wonder what do we see as we gaze out
to the world
[Music]
as a thought experiment french
psychoanalysis jacla khan
invites us to envision ourselves before
a female mantis
the female mantis is known for devouring
his partner after sex
in lakon's experiments we're wearing a
mask and we do not
know whether the mask represents us as a
female or male
and therefore we don't know whether or
not we will be eaten by the female
mantis
we simply do not know what we are to the
other
and we often project our own very biases
to the other
in order to understand the other
in fact we don't see anyone as they are
rather we see them
as we are
and how we are is informed by the
conformity to many of behavioral
assumptions dictated by laws and customs
although the colonial racist and sexist
gays
might project oppression backwardness
and terrorism onto the image of muslim
woman
wearing a borja i would like to stress
the inherent difference between a mask
and masquerade
while the mask hides the masquerade
reveals
but perhaps we could suggest that both
are acting to some extent
as a shield against the intrusive gaze
[Music]
this project is inspired by the
historical mask worn by bandarivi men
from saturn iran it has been said that
this mask were developed during
portuguese colonial rule
as a way of protecting the vera from the
gaze of
slave master looking for pretty women
from these iranian masks protecting
women from the patriarchal oppression
to mask of norse west coast indians to
mask born
as political statements must take on
range of different religious social and
political roles
and offer an interesting insight into
how we could use them
to either conceal or reveal our
identities
while these iranian masks cover most of
the wearer's face
except the eye i've been wondering how
the eyes
could be used as an expressive medium
for communication
in my research i came across an
interesting incident
in which an american officer uses
blinking to send a secret message
in this video you're saying admiral
germia denton
linking the word torture using morse
code during his captivity
well i don't know what is happening
but whatever the position of my
government
is i support it fully
whatever the position of my government
is i believe in it yes sir
i'm a member of that the use of code for
communication
is nothing new and in fact women came up
with
a code word as a method for reporting
domestic abuse
during this lockdown
in this project i was particularly
inspired by a recent experiment
involving two ai bots at the facebook ai
lab
the intention was to monitor how two
bots might develop
a dialogue however during this
experiment the bots
seemingly started to formulate their own
language
a language that no human could
understand the researchers
um had to intervene and tweaked
algorithms to prevent this from
happening
the story could also reveal how
knowledge is power
and inability to understand unnerves
those who wish to maintain their
authority
the source text of this project i used
the seminal article
candice of alternate speak by the
feminist theorist gayatri spibak
she asked whether it might be possible
for the colonized
or the subaltern to have a voice in the
face of colonial oppression
using machine learning algorithm we can
use markov chain to create a text
we represent each words as a state
and view transitions as the likelihood
that a specific world might go after
another
we can consider these states at either a
ward or character level
and we can analyze what the probability
might be
of a given letter appearing after three
letters
the engrams of a given text provides a
strategy for generating the next text
the markov chain could be therefore used
to generate texts
where each new letters is dependent upon
the previous letters
as the mass communicates using ble
protocol the algorithm
is repeated and the n grams changes
the smaller the engram gets the less
meaning there is in
in the generated text from the
linguistic perspective
each letter generated through this
process is translated into
morse code which informs the movement of
the actuators
in the video documentation of this
project which will be shown shortly
you will see two v men wearing masks
covered with eyelashes controlled by ai
they begin to communicate with each
other blinking their eyelashes in rapid
succession
the aim is to develop a secret message
for transmitting information between
multiple women
the project brings together design
critical thinking
feminism and ai
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
my
[Music]
vincent churchill once said we shape our
tools and thereafter our tools shape us
but doesn't this suggest a form of
technological determinism
after all there is no inherent
application for any tool
a knife could be used as a mirror weapon
or just as a tool for cutting an
apple similar arguments could be made
about surveillance the question we
should ask
are in what context how and for whom
are we using it we should be aware of
potential problems with ai
for once an issue is recognized as
problem it becomes a different kind of
problem
it becomes a problem not by which we are
trapped but rather
with which we can deal
is certainly a problem which originates
from human beings
and is replicated and even exacerbated
in ai
as we are training the artificial
algorithms to learn to see the world
it is important to ask ourselves what
does it mean to be seen by the machine
and through the lens of what kind of
data are they trying to look out
to the world
so thanks so much benaz for the
fascinating
creative and evocative talk and one of
the things that
your talk brought to mind for me
was that you're looking both at issues
that are implemented and instantiated by
the machine
so the gaze of the machine you know the
really surveillance technologies and so
forth as well as the kind of human
phenomena
that uh that that you're discussing and
putting in a dialogue with critical
theory and the arts
and so i was struck by one phrase early
on in your talk where you
you know mentioned about a
resistive strategies against these kind
of
issues whether it's a kind of
objectifying gaze
or other forms of discriminatory
surveillance and so you mentioned
that certain resistive strategies can be
proved to be effective in art and design
practices
and so i wonder just for you what what
does it mean
for a resistive strategy to be proved
effective
in art and design practice
um thank you so much for the great
question fox and also
before i answer i want to say that it's
a great honor to be in such an
inspiring lineup of speakers i'm honored
to be here
um to answer your question i think um
yeah like uh
especially from art and design
perspective
um i'm particularly interested in ways
that we can use
various computational systems and
repurpose those
in order to bring a new sort of insights
or in a way kind of subvert certain
dominant assumptions that we have either
through our culture
or through a sort of technological
assumptions that we have
um so it's always this sort of having
um a hand on the technology
and and um in order to subvert it in a
way
um in particular i would say i'm really
inspired also by the work of other
artists such as christopher disco and
his notion of interrogative
design in which we really look at design
as a way of
addressing larger social political
cultural issues
and so in my case particularly i'm
interested to use a lot of computer
vision technologies embedded in the
substrate of the matter
and see that how materials could be
intelligence and
smart enough but also to address
larger issues in order to empower those
that
for instance um in the latest project
the women that they were oppressed or
sort of um yeah oppressed under colonial
um oppression how we can empower those
uh
through the use of technology uh so it's
always sort of
um bringing um technology and
repurposing
it um and give it a certain twist for
um sort of envisioning what that future
would look like
i think thanks so much for the
elaboration and maybe if we continue
down the
same path you know there in the in the
same phrase you know there's the
particular word
of proof and so you know for some
for a researcher such as john a proof
has a
very particular kind of set of a very
particular kind of meaning
and a researcher such as ruja might use
a
a term such as uh demonstrate you
depending on the kind of work that she
is is doing and so in work where you're
building evocative objects you know
maybe to
to spark critical reflection does prove
mean
something kind of like you can
demonstrate that people
think critically after engaging with
this work
or yeah is there some something else
that you're aiming for so again what is
it
in some sense what does it mean to uh
prove within the domain in which you
operate
i think a lot of time perhaps it's
bringing a new type of questions
so it's bringing a new sort of uh
what if questions what if women
were able to experience the gaze of
other and their body as they're entering
the public space
i think um bringing this type of
provocative questions and creating
conversations
and sort of sharing this word with
others and it creates sort of
uh i would say an escape or a sort of
imagination for how we can really sort
of
reuse or repurpose these technologies in
a novel way
that reflect on critical issues on
issues related either to feminism
or critical studies and i'm really
interested to see how
how the world of design and art could
learn from those disciplines
and sort of combine and merge them
together in order to empower
um the sort of
those communities thanks i really love
this
idea you know that that we're describing
the role of the arts not to answer
questions but to provoke questions and
through those questions people can
better understand the operations of
these kind of systems that
impose bias and to provoke those kind of
questions
then imagination aesthetics
you know culture subjectivity all of
those kind of issues within the
the realm of the work that you're doing
become crucial for that kind of practice
you know so
i really appreciate the kind of insights
that you've brought
and it's also a kind of segue because
now we have all of the panelists
together and some time to engage
in uh questions as a as a group
and so i'd like just to begin to
transition
into those questions and maybe pick up
with
one that came up uh earlier you know in
my question with john and he mentioned
maybe that would be a great thing to
talk about as a
panel and what the observation was
it was this idea that in uh
john's work he's showing that a
particular type of a
system yeah you know if you know if you
in that case you know blind the
algorithm to race but if you blinded any
particular kind of
social issue that relates to
discrimination then you could
inadvertently detract from fairness and
then the other thing that i mentioned
was that in in
the social sciences of the idea of
colorblind racism which
seems to have a very strong parallel to
this you know to this kind of
algorithmic insight and so
maybe to begin i could ask rouhan the
same question yeah so
what yeah what is your take on
reconciling this idea that uh
computationally blinding algorithms from
race detracts from fairness
and then socially colorblindness you
know also detracts from fairness or even
more uh encodes uh uh racism you know so
can you just elaborate on what you see
coming from that connection
yeah can you re-think the question a bit
it's it's a little hard for me to
uh
sure oh sure i'd be happy to yes so
it's really just reconciling i think a
similar insight coming from two points
of
view and so in computer science the idea
is
that when you look at
fairness through the lens of estimation
approaches
objective function functions even formal
definitions
within that within that domain then
john has found that landing an algorithm
to race detracts from furnace
and i know that that's also an idea
within uh
sociology from another perspective you
know the idea that
colorblindness you know that is blinding
you know
or yeah ignoring the role of race
also detracts from fairness and so i'd
ask if you could elaborate
on that from your lens as well you know
the kind of role
of uh obscuring an issue such as uh
race and the way that that can end up
detracting from fairness
yeah i certainly can um so it is true
and you
you know you cited bonilla silva and
others
where you know it just comes down to
this
faulty notion that you know ignoring
something makes it go away
and really it's just a way of delaying
thought or action around it now
something i want to put in conversation
with this idea of colorblind racism
is that paying attention to things
collecting data on issues that
oftentimes weep and moving away from
ignoring
um assume that simply producing
knowledge or highlighting or exposing
certain issues through the use of data
and various tools
is itself a solution and an idea that i
write a little bit about
in race after technology is this notion
of
the datification of injustice
that is to say that we are often
asking questions about issues that we
we should or we could already sort of
have the answers to that is to say we're
producing more and more data and
knowledge about problems
that we know exist in some cases that we
know how to tackle and that there's not
the social and political will to deal
with
and so i want to put on the table this
idea that yes ignoring
let's say racism and other forms of
inequality it certainly stands in the
way
of social change and transformation but
sometimes
too the the call for
more and more data uh and exposure of
issues
can also be a delaying tactic to
acting on what we already know and so
that's a different
way of complicating the notion of paying
attention to issues
is not a straightforward solution it can
actually stand in the way of making
change as well
yeah thanks so much for the for the
point and i saw
john nodding as you speak yes so could
you maybe
also respond to ruja's notion you know
that sometimes
data collection or even uh big data can
it could be seen as a stalling tactic or
or even
just uh even if not in intentionally
could have that kind of effect
and then also you know maybe relate your
notion
of uh algorithmic fairness to the kind
of
sociological notion of that that has
just
described sure yeah i know i think
thanks for that
those those points and thanks for the
yeah i think that's
those are very uh important things to
keep in mind that there is this
this kind of continuum where um you know
obviously not paying attention to things
uh you know poses these problems but
that
there could be a point where we have um
essentially what you said like we've
we've collected data we're aware of the
problem and
what we need next is not more data
collection or more intensive
uh analysis of that um i mean a couple
of
things that seem interesting here is one
one level of
of of scale so there's collecting data
about the aggregate nature of the
problem
that we recognize there's a policy
change that needs to be made we have the
ample evidence for that
and then they're sort of collecting
nature about the individual uh problem
in a particular instance right so
for example if a person believes that
their particular workplace
you know is engaging in discriminatory
behavior
even if we have enormous data about the
aggregate effects of discrimination we
may have much data about you know the
effect in their particular
place of work that's a situation where
as these
as these systems become more
quantitative we have the potential to
turn the argument from one that might
have been present four decades ago where
it now comes down to a sort of
qualitative estimation of what the what
the environment there was what the
decision making was
where we may have much more deep
detailed traces at the level of the
individual now
detailed traces of the level of the
individual i think it's been interesting
in
all three of the the talks that we saw
that there's this interesting tension
that it you know it brings up both
concerns as we collect this information
but it can also be used
um as a you know a source of
power for someone who potentially is
affected by these now i was certainly
very interested sort of the relation um
in in in
in the the third talk about you know
some of the ways in which these these
technologies can be used
on both sides of it so i think the
aggregate versus the individual is
interesting
um i also think it's it's a very
interesting point about
um the sort of collecting more data can
be a stalling tactic because
it's a interesting i think how
widespread uh that
certainly can be in computer science so
if we choose areas
uh you know of course i don't wanna say
even if we choose quite different areas
with computer science and you know i
don't want to say anything that would be
you know controversial for my colleagues
in cryptography and security but i think
one
one tension that comes up there in a
very different context is that there are
systems that we know are insecure
and there comes a point where people say
we don't more attacks on these systems
to demonstrate their insecurity
what we need is a more principled way of
building them you know and so i think
often
what we have is the sort of collection
the enumeration of problems at some
point needs to
give way to the articulation of more
principled solutions
all right thanks so much and yeah what
yeah
you meant you know so john mentioned in
his uh
talk about the role of policy in terms
of solutions and then uh
rouhan just mentioned the kind of issue
of uh
yeah that there are some of these kind
of questions around bias when which
there's
an immense amount of wisdom and
strategizing and history
already and so the next question is for
benaz yeah
which is what what do you see as a role
of art and design then
for it for maybe influencing policy
makers
or for instantiating some of the kind of
some of the kind of practices that we
already know
well from other other domains how can
art and design play uh play a role in
these kind of processes
yeah i think um uh it's a great question
and like um
in terms of like i think um developments
of some sort of ethical guidelines would
be obviously
one way to start but also i really think
especially for art and design
i think one of the important aspects of
that is education
what i'm extremely excited about is to
teach
next generation of designers to be able
to
not look at these systems as sort of
black box that they have no clue how it
works but they actually
understand how it works how they can
train their own data sets
how they can understand ai system as
something that they can tinker
and prototype and
repurpose them and and don't wait for
sort of
big large corporates to sort of dictate
what is the future of technology
but we actually take active role
in participating in shaping the
conversation around the technology
so that's what i think that i really
hope that
in general um we see in education
a system in art and design particularly
to really the notion of literacy
um coming from um iran and knowing that
sometime it can be difficult to have
access to knowledge and education
or limited access i think it's very
important to open these borders and open
the knowledge and share
knowledge as much as possible if people
know how ai system
how computer vision technology works and
they start tinkering with these
technologies
that would empower them and would
empower and open up new possibilities
for the world of art and design
so i'm extremely excited about that
possibility
i think so much and one of the things
that you mentioned in
your in in your talk and the q
a afterwards was the role of the
imagination and so what you bring to
mind
are works such as octavia butler's
kindred
joanna russes the female man or ralph
ellison's
invisible man so works that you could
say from one lens or all within
speculative the domain of speculative
fiction but i actually think
are some of the great uh sociological
treatises
of our time in the last century
precisely because
they can evoke and change minds through
metaphor
and other types of interpretive means
not only
through say quantitative or
qualitative studies even so the next
question will be one
that comes from the audience and
and let's say i think this one will go
to john
it's is it possible to find or create
truly unbiased data
and if not how do we avoid imbuing any
data with our own implicit biases
um yeah obviously a great question and
i don't think the one that there's a
simple answer to but
i mean i think if you were going to you
know make the argument that
there really is no such thing as
unbiased data i think you would you know
you would start from the observation
that
you know it's in the nature of
computation to work in
inside an abstraction i mean i think
that's you know that's both the
sort of power in the limitation of the
computational approach right as computer
scientists were taught to create
abstraction barriers
um you know between the world which is
very complicated in
the system you know that we're building
the system that we're
working in and so i think the
you know and that again gives gives
computer science i think abstraction
barriers give technological systems
much of their power there are many
examples of this right the fact that you
can
in non-pandemic times perhaps fly into
an airport
rent a car and start driving that car
down the highway
a you know a dangerous potentially
life-threatening activity
it's a car you've never seen before you
have no idea how the engine works but
because it presents to you the
abstraction of a steering wheel a gas
pedal and a brake pedal
you're able to sort of put your life in
its hands um even though you've never
seen it before
so abstraction is an incredibly powerful
thing but abstraction is extremely
reductive right the car might be a
hybrid car it might be
you know some new high-tech kind of
engine we don't really know how it works
this a similar way i think any act of
sort of building a computational model
is that same kind of reduction
and so there's going to be design
decisions that go into that
i think that's the sense in which data
will be inevitably imbued with with
bias i think you know and now this is
the part of the answer that i think you
know is
you know in some ways you know more
aspirational than than concrete at the
moment but i think
one of you know one of the things i
think is promising in you know in the
kinds of
in the in the way research has been
going over the past several years
is you know they're really rapidly
widening scope of the conversation
around the construction of data sets
the construction of computational models
it's just sort of on you know and
understand both the computer science
side
and outside computer science that this
is this is a sort of
first order activity that that everyone
needs to participate in
uh this is not sort of inside any one
field
um and i think you know that's that i
think is
going to be a way to at least be begin
making progress
oh yeah thanks so much you know so if if
i i can just
insert a couple of my own views and then
i'll have the next question which is for
uh
uh rooha benjamin you know so you know i
just wanted to say something because uh
my book phantasmal media approached
imagination computation expression was
on the screen i saw before
i spoke and the central idea is that
while people often think of
computing as a objective utilitarian
and a cultural actually computing
implements various forms of subjectivity
is always
cultural and can be used to spark a
criticality and so
you know i don't i didn't write using
exactly this was from a while ago before
the term algorithmic bias was quite in
uh
parlance you know but one of the one of
the key ideas was that all technical
systems are
cultural systems and just as an example
even something like the stored program
architecture you know the bundling
machine it's like you know nearly every
computing system we use
is grounded in the culture of its times
if you go back and read the original
paper it's not abstracted like the way
we describe now
it describes input and output quote
organs of machines and it says computers
should be made of vacuum tube elements
and all these other things that
we have left by the wayside that are
entirely grounded within its
it's a time period and cultural history
and so i think it's just something we
need to be
aware of is that even systems we think
of as most objective and a cultural
implement various forms of uh culture
and so the question that i have for uh
ruha i think it it was sparked by
something
that uh that binaz said but i think that
it uh
it's rel it resonates with your talk as
well
which is about tools of resistance so
banas spoke
about artistic tools of resistance you
know the question is
broader and yeah i think it's relevant
for you because you talk about
communities and how communities can
resist against
certain types of technologies that you
know that impose
bias and so the question is are tools of
resistance ones that cannot be co-opted
by those being resisted and if i can add
are tools that cannot be co-opted even
possible so
yeah anyway that's my question
yeah i appreciate that and and and just
before i jump into this i also wanted to
build on something else
benaz was saying about the role of art
the arts
um in terms of our ethical framework and
i would say
you know in terms of our imagination
one of the things that i really want to
insist upon
is that the arts it shouldn't be an
afterthought it shouldn't be something
that we bring in
you know after the algorithms are
designed or after the technical system
in order to create kind of a sheen or a
gloss but really to understand
that imagination is a battlefield
and that in terms of imagination
certain imaginations are being codified
in our technical systems and one of the
ways to understand
the role of the arts is to radically
expand our imagination through the
questions that are asked
through the different frameworks that
are brought to bear ethical and
otherwise
and so again to understand the
centrality of imagination and everything
that we're doing not
simply in the realm that are dubbed the
arts and so that's
that's something i just want to put on
the table which relates to
this idea of tools i don't think there
are any tools that are immune from
co-optation
and but what i would suggest is that you
know in terms of trying to prevent that
understanding that tool making
um one it doesn't just apply
to hardware and software so one of the
things that i
really want us to consider are the many
types of
social tools tools of interaction
relationality that digitally come to
mind when we say the word technology and
so to have a much more expansive
understanding of what counts as tools
and to understand that you know in terms
of the power
the way that power is laden in tools
it's not a one-time
thing where you you know at the point of
creation of something that
it sets it off in a certain trajectory
either we're helping the oppressed or
empowering
you know certain groups but it's an
ongoing
battle it's an ongoing form of
resistance and so in that case
i don't think that there's a way to
immunize
uh any of our technologies from
co-optation or frame being used in ways
that were not
intended and so that's why we have to
build into the process
forms of accountability where we
continually
calibrate and think about if how and if
these tools are being used
to reinforce the status quo
reinforce power and inequality or
being used to subvert it and to
transform it and so it really has to be
an ongoing
process of accountability that's
institutionalized
that's not simply left to individuals
who
may or may not have good intentions i
think the stakes are too high
to think of the issues that we're
wrestling with on this panel simply in
terms of ethics or the ethics of
individuals or even fields
but we really have to build it create an
ecosystem
forms of regulation accountability
protections
that operate whether or not individuals
have the best intentions i think we
can't
rest our build our futures
on the well-meaning intent not to do
harm
as important as that is right
so what i love in your response are
well i was gonna say two things but
actually all of it but two things i'll
call attention to in particular
were one this idea about
computing as a tool it's a very
instrumental view
of computing you know because computing
can be used in
so many broader ways whether it's purely
for
you know the kind of austere beauty of
formalization you know or it could be
something such as
in some of the the communities that i
work in
seeing the computer as a medium not just
as a tool so when you ask that question
can media be co-opted you know then it
becomes a little bit more obvious you
know then when you say
can a tool be co-opted and then finally
the reason i wanted to bring this
together with a second point that you
made was about
the arts not being an afterthought
because i think oftentimes that comes
from when the arts are seen
in an instrumental way and so let's say
if someone's applying for a national
science foundation grant
and then say okay i have my intellectual
merit arts wig
will be broader impact i'll bring in an
artist afterwards and they can help me
to spit dissemination
and so yeah it's yeah so when when arts
are thought of is that in that
instrumental way it often
leads to them being that kind of
afterthought
and so the next question is for benaz
which is
i think related to this idea of an
instrumental view
of of of technologies being
co-opted and so you know the question
is asking about your thoughts around
gender that stem from your work and the
way
that uh you know that
that your your work operates as
a critique of heteronormativity of
heterosexual normativity
and but they're also wondering
about the ways that uh heterosexual
normativity might be reinforced by
this kind of work and then they ask you
know how a kind of gender fluid
a gender fluid perspective on the issue
of gays
or a perspective influenced by queer
theory
might inform your work differently and
then just as the final
editorial remark on their question you
know because
we talked about deep learning i mean
with deep fake technologies
the major way that they're being used
the most prevalent use is actually a
sexual objectification like you
mentioned
and in fact creating uh new pictures of
celebrities and so forth you know that's
the most uh
prevalent use of those technologies out
there which seems very related to this
idea
of the sexualizing gays so what would
the lenses of gender fluidity and queer
theory bring to the kind of work that
you do
wow that's that's a difficult one but
i'll try to
answer as best as i can um yeah so
it's it's fascinating because uh for
instance in chris of the gays the the
projects that track the gaze of the
onlooker
um i was using a system that
it was pre-trained i was using a
pre-trained model that it was um
basically able to uh or sort of
predicting the gender in a very binary
way
which we know it's very problematic um
if there is a male or a female
and so um as a designer although i use
both uh systems that they are trained
based on
sort of pre-trained data or in some
cases i train the system with
certain data um i think it's fascinating
to just
kind of address these issues and
particularly as you mentioned
regarding let's say gender fluidity
can computational system really predict
through the pure representation
or identification and i think folks from
that point of view your work
particularly
actually address these issues that how
our identity is being represented in
um virtual environments um
and um i think a lot of times for me
is to sort of either use them or
kind of question them um i think
also i have to mention that this notion
of essentialism
which is very dominant in feminist
discourse
um could we actually say that there is
anything essential about being a female
expert
being a female and having a female
experience uh
obviously it's been in um sort of
western way of thinking
um and there are and many theories that
question that sort of essentialism in
art and design practices
having said that also i have to
acknowledge that coming from a culture
that
it's mainly male dominant um
you are still struggling with a lot of
sort of these gender binary
differences um so i
i don't have a sort of uh answer
how computational systems could address
the gender fluidity because it's
absolutely uh complicated topic
but i think it's also very very
interesting to think about
like how are we going to represent our
identities
so i would like to also hear from you
fox what are your thoughts on that
yeah sure yeah so i got to speak briefly
and then i have another question for
john and so one is i try to reconcile
between domains by
you know so i mentioned computer science
speech i also have degrees in
uh art as as well and so one of the
things i have to do then is
think about the values within each
domain you know so is it something like
generalizability
is it is is it a value like how
exhaustive and efficient is this
particular algorithm that i've created
or is it something like can the system
spark criticality you know
and within society or can it even be
used
practical and can you this is maybe more
like some of the work in the social
sciences
can you demonstrate that this work
empirically
sparks a reflection say using some kind
of validated instrument
and so when reconciling between those
domains
then i often find insights such as when
critiquing
a system let's say a computer science
system that was created
to you know to help girls learn
mathematics
then you can ask questions such as but
what
what model of gender is the system
working under is this a
biological positivist model of gender in
which all girls are assumed to learn in
the same kind of way
or is it something where their girl
girlhood is not necessarily
understood to be something which is
monolithic across them
so then you can interrogate the
technical practices in a very different
way when you begin to
think about how it's instantiating
particular sets of values and
and so i think what you were mentioning
in particular i have one
patented computational system which is
for representing identity very
differently than
in the top-down way many computational
systems do it's essentially not trying
to put you into
a box you know by some set number of
fields but actually implements fluidity
you know that is
you have a trajectory in which you
naturalize into categories degrees of
membership and categories multiple
categories so your identity isn't
fixed at any one particular location and
it can be applied to so many different
things like ranging from
music you know because our taste might
be different in the morning than in the
evening
or it could or some of the more you know
the kind of issues of bias that we've
spoken about in conversation here
i'll leave it at that end and then that
and you know maybe we could continue uh
later but
i want to just say one more thing folks
um
that um this somehow we are complicit in
this i mean the fact that we
already have lgbtq we have this form of
identification
that at the end people have to put
themselves in the boxes to identify as
one of those categories
this would sort of originate from that
point of view and then
kind of replicates in our computational
systems
so my point is that it's the issue is so
complex because
in our actual way that we are also
identifying
the society we are constantly creating
these boxes that you mentioned
and we add more categories and we think
that by adding
more categories everyone should find
their own identification
but we truly have to question um uh
how we operate um uh even in the society
in the first place rather than sort of
how this system also replicate in in
computational systems
right yeah that's exactly right i mean i
use the term box fx describe
all the kind of discriminatory fallout
that comes from that kind of taxonomic
perspective
on identity and maybe more evocatively
jeff balker and lee scott
lee star with the term identity torque
this idea that when you don't fit into
those identity
categories being forced by society it
actually produces
torque on the individual you know that
is actual
emotional pain because people have
experiences that they can't
reconcile with how they see themselves
and you know so there's so so much more
we can i can say about this but you know
such
important points and so one question
that we have
from you know from the audience actually
from will lockett who is one of
the uh co-organizers of
the uh unfortunate intelligence
symposium
asked about the capacity of mathematics
to represent so i'll use his terms and
then also say the way that i interpret
it which is
the capricious specificity of individual
behavior
as in some agent-based simulation
and i think really it's very similar to
the first question
that uh i asked uh or actually the
ending question
in the q a after john's session which
was
is computing is using mathematical
approaches
always going to be reductive or is there
some way that those approaches can be
used you know
that are complementary to other types of
approaches and are not necessarily going
to be reductive in
harmful ways
um yeah it's a great question and i mean
i think it's
it's sort of a question that comes up a
lot when we talk about building
mathematical models
of of the world um and i think you know
in particular
mathematical models of the
social world and you know it it already
begins with you know
the fact that a lot of our you know a
lot of people's education
sort of trains them in the intuitions
around building mathematical models of
simple physical systems and there's
always this sort of optimistic sense
that maybe i can take what i learned
there and begin to
apply it to um situations in the
social world and and obviously you know
we've run into an enormous number of
challenges there in particular that the
state of the world
in in the case of the social world
typically is uh ex
you know has an extremely long
description right in in in the language
of
features it's extremely wide there are
many many different things that i
know about an individual um what their
experiences are
uh what what their what their actions
are what their motivations and intents
are
and as a result to
represent that you know it's something
where we we can't really hope to
fully either know or or uh represent all
those things and that's why
i think we end up with some of these um
some of these challenges so
i you know i think i'm um you know i
personally tend toward optimism that
this is an activity that we should be
engaging in because i think it's a
valuable
uh sort of supplement to the the the
kinds of discussions which are taking
place
but we certainly i don't think see any
evidence that it's a
you know it's a substitute for these
these these other forms of analysis
right
i think it's it it it supplements it and
if we think of it as a supplement you
know then we can begin to
look for a way you know in the spirit
that i think you know um
has been been true in all the talks and
you know i i think
ben is that you you service very
powerfully the multiple uses of the same
you know the same tool or the same
methodology you know to look for ways in
which
um you know reductiveness can
you know some sometimes expose
commonalities across situations that we
think of as
very different um and i think if that's
done in
in partnership with a conversation that
recognizes the differences across these
domains then it can establish linkages
that may actually provoke further
thinking i think if it's
done to the you know in the absence of
that that that conversation then it
it just ends up obscuring uh
obscuring important distinctions
thanks you know it reminds me of a
statement made by the late great uh
computer scientist uh joseph gogan who
met who just you know said something
to the effect of we can describe
subjective social phenomena in uh
subjective
ways or critical ways and we can also
describe them
in precise ways and it doesn't none of
these
it gives additional authority to the
analysis they're just different
languages for doing the analysis
and so when you say complementary i feel
like that's one of the
keys just understanding whether it's the
imaginative like uh
like you know like and uh's work
as well as i've seen her work bridge
with the uh
arts uh too yeah or the you know the
mathematical
yeah it's uh it's just different lenses
that again can be complementary
in addressing related uh related issues
and so i want to also just
since we have just a few more minutes
left ask if
any of the panelists have questions for
one another
i'll take the opportunity not not
necessarily to pose
a question but just to be in
conversation and
and two quick things one is on your last
point
fox about the compliment or and also
john's point about the complementarity
i i want us to think about that in
relation
to the very real hierarchies of
knowledge in the academy
that while ideally these fields would be
complementary
there are certain forms of knowledge
that have more that are granted more
authority
and more legitimacy that even in
collaboration trump other forms of
knowledge and they follow along
predictable lines
hard to soft the qualitative the
quantitative etc
and at the same time i i just want to
say that
we've spent some time talking about the
relationship between computation and
reductive racist sexist forms of
hierarchy but i also want to
call my own fields into complicity the
social sciences and the humanities
and that storytelling can be just as
violent
and just as reductive in terms of
infusing
all kinds of meaning in the world so
it's not simply
on the statistical or the computational
side that this kind of reckoning needs
to happen but also in the humanities and
social sciences
that have been some of the major
producers of this racist architecture
that we still inhabit and so no field is
immune from the kind of questions
and um reckoning that i think we're
talking about
especially important points you know
they both call to mind this notion of
cultural humility which often is not
used related to academic disciplines but
i think you give an exact
a good description of why it should be
applied to those uh to those such
disciplines and so we're you know
we're coming down to just our last uh
last seconds here you know so yeah i
appreciated that final remark in terms
of bringing the different ideas
into conversation with one another i
would like just to
welcome if john and then uh have just
very brief closing
remarks uh too you know then then we
could
happen we can do so and then
um i yeah i first of all
i would say you know it's been a
privilege to be able to to take part in
the conversation
with um uh with all of you and uh you
know
with the insights have been expressed
across different fields and fox thanks
very much for your moderation of the
panel because i think your work
really has sort of um encompasses
so many of the themes that we've been
seeing here and you know has been i
think inspirational to
you know uh a lot of people including
myself and i think
what you know what this panel sort of
embodies and microcosm is
certainly the the the type of analysis
which you know i sort of
you know think on the computational side
that you know i think uh
people have been increasingly aspiring
to to actually
you know bring the mathematical
formalism in the model z
you know into a a closer conversation
you know both with the arts and the
social sciences and to
understand how it can you know inform
that discussion um
you know without as ruja said sort of
overly dominating that discussion
and thanks so much just being a cultural
humility made me feel
very humble in your remarks uh too as
well as appreciate your insight
so uh yeah uh benaz can you uh
impossible
uh of course and i just wanna very
briefly echo
um um uh uh john's comments and
and and i i wanna say that also thank
you fox for organizing this panel i've
learned from all the speakers here
i think um the opportunities for artists
and designers and
and to learn from other disciplines but
also have the sort of
transdisciplinary approach and that can
learn and borrow from each disciplines
it's incredible in this period of time
so
i'm extremely excited um about the
possibility of learning from other
disciplines and bringing those ideas
into my own discipline and art and
design
and so thank you so much for creating
and
uh fostering this platform
well thank you so much and i want to
finally just extend heartfelt thanks to
uh
rooha john and benaz for agreeing to
join this uh
panel i've learned so much and been so
inspired by all of the things that
you've said
and also thanking the co-conveners of
this the symposium
and uh and you know
those who came up with the idea of
unfolding
intelligence as a convening
maybe a year or more ago and to see it
finally come
into fruition in you know this time of
great reckoning we find ourselves in
right now so it's a you know just an
astounding and impressive
and valuable feat you know to bring us
all together here so thank you very much
thanks for audi and thank you thank you
to our audience as well
and have a great rest of the symposium
you